this song from the new album is called
left and right
and you said I came to you in a dream or
something right uh this song well I I
remember I was um listening to Yellow
Submarine in the town
and his voice is on the left side of the
speaker and that I always I was curious
about that and there wasn't any Google
when I was like eight nine years old or
maybe there was I just didn't know how
to use it and I found out that the
reason why that was due to the recording
limitations sometimes you'd get uh Paul
or in this case Ringo's voice on the
same side of where the drums are going
to be because he only had eight tracks
to record on and I remember falling
asleep and being like I should play with
panning in my vocal I should call the
song left and right and I should sing
as if I'm in the inside of my brain
because how many songs have you heard
you take up every corner of my mind I
can't get you off my mind one if I was
singing in my brain and I was pointing
to the direction of my brain you take
over this corner of my brain and this
corner of my brain so you won't be able
to hear it now because I don't know how
much panning ability we have but if you
hear the uh original version it's quite
creative where you hear this vocal like
I'm speaking right now on the left hand
side of your headphones and then I'm
going to the right hand side of your
headphones kind of theatrical in a way
here are the boys this is Charlie and
Jan doing their thing Charlie and John
memories
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
you'll go around Circle sky is stuck up
in my head memories
[Music]
your love stays with me day and night
night
[Music]
[Applause]
how much more
[Music]
[Applause]
stuck up in my head memories
[Music]
down now I take up every corner of my
mind
your love stays with me day and night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
memories
[Music]
[Music]
take up every corner
[Music]
um